if I could compel anybody or everybody
here to take a real step back and
understand this most important part the
people that amass 10 million followers
on tick tock two years ago today would
only amass 300 000. attention on the
Internet is like the real estate
business the first movers get the best
real estate even though every day people
continue to not take full advantage of
this every day many others do and the
supply and demand of content versus the
attention on the other side continues to
shift the single biggest way for anybody
in this room to double the size of their
business
no question given the makeup of this
industry is through a significant
content strategy on LinkedIn good
afternoon
um
very excited and humbled to be here uh
uh really really nice to be with you so
let's go into the two Frameworks of what
I'd like to talk about uh this afternoon
one is
the marketing variable of 2023 and
Beyond in a B2B environment in a service
business and to the elephant in the room
of where we are in managing people in a
2023 world
around the framework of their
opportunities and Alternatives instead
of working for us
working for themselves or finding other
variables for me when I understand the
makeup of this room
where I'm always passionate to go in a
talk like this
is operational practicality you know I
grew up in a family business everything
was very business oriented and the
reality is when it comes both to
marketing and when it goes to people
management there's a lot of
pontification a lot of Sizzle a lot of
fluff and at the end of the day not a
lot of actual action around those two
categories when in my opinion
for a staggering amount of the people in
this room they are the two largest
variables
of where the business is going and what
the opportunities slash vulnerabilities
are within our businesses so I currently
run a service-based business I have
about 1200 employees globally like we
run a very large marketing agency and
what's been really fascinating about my
transition in my career from building my
dad's liquor store through marketing and
operations and then being a early
investor in Silicon Valley startups like
Facebook Twitter and Tumblr to then
going into client service both with
vaynermedia which is Fortune 500
companies in the B2B and b2c space but
also a company called the Sasha Group
which is named after my dad that really
Services businesses that are doing
between one and 10 million dollars in
revenue is
the framework of where I want to go with
my talk so first and foremost
what's crazy
in the excitement I have to deliver is
the opportunity that is linked in today
for a lot of people in this room so I'm
sure this is going to make sense for a
lot of you because a lot of you have
watched this navigation happen LinkedIn
over the last 15 years has gone from a
place where it was all about just
recruiting and HR and hiring to over the
last five to seven years
and really in the last three years a
very heavy content platform where people
are consuming a lot more content in the
platform I would argue today that
LinkedIn in 2022 is more similar to
where Facebook was seven or eight years
ago than what we all grew up with
LinkedIn looking like 10 years ago what
I mean by that is there is not a single
day that goes by that I don't get at
least three to five messages on my
LinkedIn or my email
that I don't get a message from a small
business owner that has just landed
their first sales opportunity or their
biggest client through a single piece of
content on LinkedIn inspired by a piece
of content I created on LinkedIn that
made them actually make it when I think
about what could I bring in value to
this talk today
no question the biggest impact in my
opinion is around the concept of how do
I get people in this room who have very
little motivation to believe in organic
content on LinkedIn as a business driver
to understand how outrageous organic
content on LinkedIn is a business driver
what's fascinating about B2B businesses
you know so you know I'm 46 years old so
I think this will make sense to a lot of
people in this room so many of my
friends and contemporaries especially
engineer based friends really ended up
in the seats in this audience if you're
of this age there was so much
opportunity in the late 90s early 2000s
beginning half of 2000s to stumble into
this industry going from helping friends
and family to starting your own shop and
so what's really obvious to me is that
this industry at this scale is
incredibly predicated on Word of Mouth
predicated on the luck of the draw on
SEO the occasional
thoughtful b2c level execution on sem
and Google ads
but is non-existent in the world that
has developed in the last five years of
a deep social media creative and media
strategy to drive business results
what's most fun about what I just said
if you follow it along at home is the
reality of how little friction there is
for this to be a meaningful impact on
the business other than and I'm
incredibly empathetic to this
a deep lack of perspective of how real
it is
so
for so many the thought of producing one
two pieces of content a day for LinkedIn
is incredibly foreign
and what do I post what will it lead to
yet for all of you that have kids that
are deep into Tick-Tock consumption
you're probably quite aware of how much
consumption they're doing in a Tick-Tock
world
and the reason that's happening is tick
tock
is based on people's interest not based
on who people follow
so tick tock's big explosion in the last
half decade has been completely
predicated on the fact that they
realized the social graph AKA who you
follow is important and was a beacon of
the last decade but the interest graph
the stuff you're actually into of the
moment is a dramatically bigger platform
that was the thesis that led me to
investing in Tumblr 15 years ago and it
had a nice exit to Yahoo but
they've expanded on it dramatically and
now all of the social networks from
Twitter to metas Facebook and Instagram
to snap will very much chase this
because it's just the reality of human
behavior why do I bring this up to all
of you
it's to give you courage permission or
at least strategy to understand that you
could go from being in this room right
now
and never posting once in your entire
life on LinkedIn and using it as a
platform
to
posting a piece of video written word
audio
about a how-to about a did you know uh a
a six sentence paragraph on why privacy
matters to your client or 800 other
variables that you want people to know
the same [ __ ] that you would tell them
if you were in a sales call or if
somebody referred them to you and you
got on the phone with them and that
LinkedIn is also working on that same
algorithm and you can go from zero
followers and no presence you might not
even have an account or you might have
an account that doesn't even have your
profile picture in it right now and your
first piece of content
has the potential
to get actual what I would call Micro
virality and begin the process
of the hypothesis that I come to this
conference with which is
I've done over the last 13 years of my
speaking career
plenty of talks I was talking backstage
I do a lot of consumer stuff where the
agency for Pepsi and Budweiser and lots
of Brands you know but the work we do
with Chase or GE or all the other B2B
entities that we work with is always
dramatically more interesting to me and
a conference like this versus people
that are at the Forefront of social is
more interesting to me
because I know how big the opportunity
is
in the marketplace because of how few
people are actually doing it and the
people that are doing it are doing it
atrociously
the reality of the majority of LinkedIn
content and all of you know that
actually by show of hands raise your
hand please appease me how many people
here
consume content on LinkedIn go into
LinkedIn they're active raise your hand
all right so this is way [ __ ] better
than I thought
so the far majority of this room
understands at least from a personal
human being standpoint that they're
consuming information on LinkedIn which
then renders all of you to completely
follow what I'm saying which is 98 of it
is garbage and it's garbage because
almost every single person that creates
LinkedIn content comes from the
perspective of sales DNA
they're posting something that is
fundamentally one hundred thousand
percent in their own vested best
interest they would like to post
something that makes all the other
people on the other side
hire them
in reality if you leave with anything
from this conference if you are doing
this actually by show of hands how many
people here are producing at least a
single piece of content a day to post
organically in LinkedIn don't raise your
hand if you're lying because I'm going
to double check and call you out on
LinkedIn so be raise your hand if you're
doing that
11.
12. all right so
what what excites me about that is just
how substantial the upside is what also
excites me is how many people raise
their hand as consumers of thus easily
creating the connection point that I'm
desperate to land here one more time
LinkedIn like every other social network
forced by the obnoxious success of tick
tock
has caused all of social media to change
in the way that all of us grew up with
it if you grew up with it professionally
I mean over the last 15 years no longer
is it overly required for you to spend
years announcing followers like an email
service
to get the content that you make to
actually be seen
LinkedIn more than any other platform
besides tick tock
overly grossly phenomenally
rewards content that people actually
want to see
literally many in this room if motivated
by this and I'm a realist I know it's
less than five percent of the people in
this room are going to actually go home
and make anything but of that five
percent
five percent of that five percent's
first post
never having anyone consume anything
from them will get tens if not hundreds
of thousands of views or reads
that becomes your business development
tool that
is no question in my opinion more than
Direct Mail more than spending more on
Google AdWords
if you're not spending a Google AdWords
you start with a base you should be in
the game
the amount of people that buy booths at
conferences
to Market to the same goddamn people
they've seen for the last 30 years
nobody here is confused
everybody here knows how shitty and how
bad marketing is and B2B client service
businesses LinkedIn came along and gave
you something that doesn't charge you
other than your time and your efforts
and the cost you put into the content
in outrageous opportunity for virality
as if you went on CNBC and talked about
your business and yet every day
every hour every minute
people are not taking advantage of it
out of sheer
philosophical ideology and talking about
things on their point of view of
LinkedIn content that they don't even
understand
or sheer laziness or sheer non-interest
to invest a couple dollars back into
their business and all of those things
I'm incredibly empathetic too
I don't come to DC to fire you up to
grow your business I genuinely don't
care
right I really don't I mean I do I would
love nothing more than you know actually
one of the things that continues to
drive me to do things like this is the
email 18 months later saying I can't
believe you came to DC I never thought
of it I never wanted to do it I thought
it was stupid I did it but the reality
is it's not my business I can only do so
much on the flip side it is literally an
enormous opportunity
and so
when we get into q a or if you want to
hit me up if you want like details of
what you should look at or what you
should read if I could compel anybody or
everybody here to take a real step back
and understand this most important part
the people that amassed 10 million
followers on tick tock two years ago
today with only amass 300 000.
the people that amassed
5 million followers on Twitter in 2010
11 12. today if they did the same exact
behaviors would only amass
a thousand five thousand
attention on the internet on platforms
that have the attention is like the real
estate business the first movers get the
best real estate
everything I'm talking about today if
you go and do this three years from now
versus tomorrow you will have
disproportionately less returns because
even though every day people continue to
not take full advantage of this every
day many others do and the supply and
demand of content versus the attention
on the other side continues to shift the
single biggest way for anybody in this
room to double the size of their
business
no question given the makeup of this
industry is through a significant
content strategy on LinkedIn
how you make that content
is a worthwhile conversation for a few
minutes that we talk about one a lot of
people just don't want to be on camera
and I respect that to no end
the way you decide your strategy on the
content is completely predicated on
self-awareness
everybody in this room needs to really
decide are they good at writing
are they willing to do video or are they
Gift of Gab and they can record it they
don't want to be on video but they can
record the audio and they're willing to
post audio
no question video over indexes
everything
on the flip side it's also the domain
that most people are uncomfortable with
because of people's insecurities around
the way they look the way they say like
you know just life and I respect that
but if you're going to go down this
journey and you consider this real
I highly recommend
that you go down video first
if you can't do that audio second
written word third and let there be no
confusion the written word is remarkably
effective if that's your best domain of
communication it's just that video does
over index that's the punch line
now
a very important little tidbit of
information that might really help a lot
of people here get started because it's
getting started that is always the
hardest part number one
just basic functionality of like how do
I put all that
you know there's
I'm excited what is that
I don't have that no
all right
um
there's somebody on my mic over here
um
people struggle with producing content
and so
one of the hacks that I've been able to
figure out that has really worked for a
lot of B2B businesses
has been the concept of the following
the idea of starting a podcast
where you interview
former
and more importantly in my opinion or
equally as important
future clients
So reading some of the people that were
using the hashtag of this event and
reading what they were talking about
let's just stick on privacy
if you decided to create a podcast
called the Privacy hour where you talk
about cyber security and things of that
nature
you basically
have a tremendous cultural hack going on
right now in our world where people are
So Thirsty to be famous that they say
yes to be on podcasts that have no
listeners
so one thing that has been unbelievably
dominant for a lot of people that have
followed this blueprint that I'm
speaking about is the concept of
reaching out on LinkedIn as well
to potential business owners that they
want to do business with and asking them
to be on their show to talk about their
business
regionalizing it or localizing it is
also a very big deal I spoke like this
once in a real estate conference and the
person followed it verbatim the way I
laid it out which was just do a show
called The Charlotte small business show
and just interview all the small
business owners in Charlotte
once a week systematically and I got
that email three years later of like
what that meant to her business as you
can imagine that blueprint for so many
people in this room
is extremely effective but here's the
key by doing the podcast
and potentially recording it on Zoom or
Google hangouts or doing in person with
a camera
the thing that I'm most interested in is
not necessarily making you the next Joe
Rogan
it's that in that 30 or 45 minutes how
many clips
you can cut to use as your LinkedIn
posts for what you're needing to do to
take advantage of what I just talked
about I'm very aware of how many people
sat here when I said
post once or twice or three times a day
on LinkedIn every day
and people like [ __ ] I've post
once in my life
so what we have to produce is a strategy
that actually allows us to get that
level of content for me no question the
number one realistic you might consider
it if you're trying to be on the offense
way to do that is to start a podcast
in my opinion based on this industry
preferably around small businesses in
your general area
and interview those business owners you
don't even go in for the close you're
just having a small some of you do this
for a living but you are the most
charismatic person at a party you you do
have that personality you kind of wish
you were a sportscaster or on TV and so
then for you you don't have to go
literal into privacy land you can go
into genre overall land of small
business land because what you're really
doing is just Biz devving relationships
as I'm sure this will make sense to
everybody here if you're trying to do
business with a lot of local businesses
within a 40-mile radius
you're going to get a lot more people
interested in talking to you if you're
asking them to come on your show and
talk about their journey of building a
business then you're going to get to do
a sales call and get them to hire you
if you record that properly and fully
understand how to chop up those pieces
of content and use them as a day in and
day out piece of content for your
LinkedIn profile for you and your
business and you add to that video three
to four to seven sentences of context
that maybe the video didn't fully hit on
that shows the world you know what
you're talking about and you come from
the lens of that content not being
a sales call
but being a source of information you
will be downright shocked on the actual
impact on your business
every day every day of my life I get
emails from people who followed it who
thought it was complete baloney I'm
incredibly empathetic to what may be
going through business owners Minds in
here around the value of social media
for their business
social media is incredibly hard
to use as a business tool because most
people don't understand what it is most
people dismiss it because they have
ideological points of view about it so
that immediately eliminates it whether
it's mad about what it does to the kids
or the world or politics or this and
that and then for the small group that
is able to stay unemotional and be a
business person it's incredibly
difficult to understand how to use it
you have to be good at it
people every day in meetings like this
or conferences like this raise their
hand and say Gary I did LinkedIn it
didn't work
I say to them what's the and they say to
me well what's the ROI of social I asked
them well what's the ROI of a basketball
and then they're confused
and then I say what's the ROI of a
basketball and then they're confused and
then I say the ROI of a basketball for
LeBron James
was billions of dollars
the ROI for basketball for me was
negative 8 000. I've had two surgeries
on my knees
I say to them
LinkedIn works you just suck at it
so so I come here this afternoon
as a very practical dude that's been
doing this a long time and I beg because
I want the karma points for everyone to
deeply understand what I'm talking about
is not fairy tale or fun
I could give a crap about LinkedIn or
Facebook or SnapChat or Tick Tock I just
care about where customers attention is
I built my Daddy's Liquor store with
direct mail and local television and
radio but when the internet came along
and I understood that I could buy Google
AdWords for five cents I did that and
when social media gets destroyed by VR
or 3D or aliens come and take us
somewhere else I'll be ready
and so I highly recommend to all of you
that you take your emotions
and you check them at the door if you're
here to be a business person I assume if
you're at a conference
on the first week after Labor Day in the
middle of the day sitting here you have
agenda and ambition and drive
I'm going to take that assumption that
you decided to be here and say that you
want something good to happen to your
career your family your business I'm
going to ask you to remind yourself that
the way you even got to the seat you're
in today is that you put in the work
often people are very passionate about
putting in the work at their craft but
they don't want to put in the work on
things that don't come easy or they
don't understand I'm incredibly aware
that marketing is a very different skill
set than a core craft that is sitting in
this room I also want to remind
everybody that marketing is the biggest
driver to business results in the world
that sales is amazing and I love being a
Salesman
but sales is just bad marketing
marketing
is the most important thing in the world
thank you Mom
I always plant my mom to start it going
I really think you can do it I even
think more Cooley for like 20 or 30
people here it's going to take them on a
journey they could have never imagined
for all the fun emails I get about like
this was good and I doubled my business
the ones that always really get me in
the stomach are the ones that say I
started doing it for this but I like the
video content so much I pivoted to this
and I was only doing this because it's
how I made my money but I didn't love it
let there be no confusion I'm wildly
aware that there's a lot of people
sitting in here today that don't love
what they're doing they do it because
it's their best and most serious way of
income
one of the great side effects of
following the model I'm telling you is
it may take you down a path you have no
idea that could be taken I'm very aware
that many people here would rather
subsidize how much money they make in
their business right now and make the
same amount by making content around
golfing or hunting
or for me the New York Jets
which pisses me off to no end let's
connect afterwards I'm really [ __ ]
pissed out here with us
haven't won a game in September in four
years anyway
I really really believe in this I know
it's true I see it every day and I
really implore all of you to take this
talk extremely seriously and at least
give it a significant at-bat of just
trying it or digging in a little bit
more I'm gonna spend the next several
minutes on one other thing how many
people here have more than five
employees raise your hand hi please okay
good then I'll go here
so I'm sure everybody's heard about the
great resignation and all this other
stuff
I just want everybody here to win in
their business and so I want to give you
a preview to something that scares me 10
000 times more for all of us that employ
people
because of what I do for a living I get
10 to 20 000 direct messages a day on
social media I spend hours every day
reading them I never read ninety percent
of them that's impossible but I have a
tremendous pulse on where things are
going which has been the foundation of
My Success
over the last two three years there's
been a phenomenon that is not being
talked about we're talking about the
great resignation and I'm reading all
the Articles we're talking about the
boomeranging and all this
but I really want to put this on the
radar of a lot of people here because I
think it could be valuable
as scary for some people as is the great
resignation I am dramatically way more
concerned about the great never applying
in the first place
we
in this room are incredibly good at
[ __ ] on gen Z and young millennials
it's one of our great talents how many
people here over 40 raise your hand
one of the best things you do is that
who's over 50 raise your hands
This Crew is the most fun because you
guys [ __ ] created them
all my oh my almonds that have like 18
to 25 year olds literally because I'm
popular in that world because of tick
tock I have 15 million followers there
so all their kids are fans and they're
always talking to me and they spend
literally the entire business dinner
[ __ ] on their kids
and then I remind them maybe you
shouldn't have given him an eighth place
trophy
[Applause]
incredible incredible phenomenon of
modern parenting that has led to
incredible levels of anxiety because we
use fear and over coddling and it comes
from a great place parenting is hard
I've got to I get it it's hard but it is
real
and we like to razz on them right
but they're smarter than you think
the reason these 15 to 25 year olds
don't want to come and work for you for
62k or 40K is because they can make that
much flipping [ __ ] on eBay
it's because they can make 100K and
brand deals on Tick Tock like that and
I'm not talking about Charlie demilio
and Logan Paul I'm talking the millions
let me say it's slow for Carl in the
back
the millions of people that are making
50 60 70 80 120 000 a year in YouTube
AdSense and brand deals on Tick Tock and
on Flipping stuff
and so they're not entitled and
overspoiled of course some are
they're just awake to their Alternatives
and many in here would be doing the same
thing if we had these options but we
just had [ __ ] Nintendo and a Walkman
we as business owners especially with
all the hands that just went up with
five and more have to take a serious
step back and understand how big of a
deal this is
you think inflation and labor costs have
got like as a problem I'm telling you
right now you have an entire generation
and I know this isn't predominantly U.S
based but for all my International
Friends this is happening even in places
that are having recessions and economic
crises
the fragmentation of opportunity because
of the internet and the emerging
blockchain we haven't even you know
we're not even going on the consumer
blockchain I don't want to overspend
time on what nfts are going to mean when
they're real not just the hype that was
last year the consumer blockchain is the
biggest invention since the internet
the internet is now mature
and humans have uncomfortable levels of
options
when I was doing wine library.com in
1996
everybody in the liquor business in New
Jersey laughed at me
and said
who's going to buy wine on the internet
when you can just go to the liquor store
and my answer was everyone
when I tell you every 13 year old in
America and most places in the world
today understand their options
and have no interest
in what you're offering we must figure
this out now
yesterday
and we need to be thoughtful about this
we need to value our employees more
that's not over I'm not looking for
eighth place trophies I just mentioned
that I'm not saying over coddle I'm
saying how many people here have under
20 employees raise your hand under 20.
for all of you I have 1200 I spend
probably
an hour and a half a day as the CEO
speaking to individual employees for 15
and 10 and five minute Pockets at a time
I have so many friends who own
businesses that have 25 employees and
they don't talk at all to 80 of their
employees in any meaningful real way as
a human being
we must bring Humanity to the workplace
not over cuddling
we must bring Humanity to the workplace
you're going to really focus on
retention this next decade and just
throwing money at the problems not going
to be enough
so I ask for all the people that have
that emotional intelligence to uh take a
step back and lean into it
if you're not selling your business and
retiring in the next five to seven years
this subject we just touched on is about
to become a major major deal and I
highly recommend you give it some real
thought
foreign
[Music]